[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who makes
breakdowns you can't hold a candle to in
this video we're going to be going over
the ending of Dungeons and Dragons honor
among Thieves the full movie is out
worldwide and in this breakdown we're
going to be going over the plot those
final few scenes and also what we
thought of the film
there's a big villain who gets
introduced here that I think we need to
talk about and after our movie recap
we'll go into where I think things will
be going with them I just want to get
straight into it but there will be heavy
spoilers from here on out so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then check out now if you enjoy the
video please hit the Thumbs Up Button
make sure you subscribe if you're Chris
Pine for more breakdowns from us crap
puns over with and without the way
thanks for clicking this now let's get
in the Dungeons and Dragons how are we
gonna pull this off we're gonna need a
team
okay so the film stars Chris Pine as Ed
gundarvis an ex-hop return Thief who is
jailed after attempting to gain a
resurrection tablet to revive his dead
wife in case you aren't up to speed with
your Dungeons and dragon's lore Hoppers
are basically a secret organization who
dedicate themselves to protecting the
Forgotten Realms Ed was one of their
best members who saved several people's
lives always hit the thumbs up button
and managed to capture many a red wizard
whether it got greedy and after taking
their Treasures they managed to fall
back home to his wife's ear and their
child Kira turns out red Wizards mock
their treasure but she was able to hide
their daughter away before she could be
found and killed by the vengeful group
of evil magicians red wizard blades
prevent resurrection and being unable to
save his wives and add into a deep and
dark depression Harpers were supposed to
do things out of the goodness of their
heart and had he not been tempted by the
treasure then his life would have taken
a different course however in the end he
decides to turn his back on golden
treasure and this is in order to save
the people of Neverwinter kind of
telling the story in a bit of an odd
order if I say the end before the middle
so we'll just wait till Jonathan gets
here and then we can start the story is
Jonathan's coming he's coming soon right
isn't he oh I got a good feeling about
this
dungeons of dragons is that classic
hero's journey we've got a ragtag group
of Misfits you know we have to fight
dragons I mean the Wizards in order to
save the world any way Ed burn the book
of the Harper called upon his wife's
funeral pyre and when doing this he
noticed the sapphire dragonfly that
comes to represent her throughout the
film Dan and his luck he ended up
meeting the Exile Barbarian hulgar and
together they raised Kira the Holger is
a member of the elk tribe who are
described as being arrogant and
ill-tempered pillagers they had very
little friends and so mixing with others
as a banishable offense Olga fell in
love with Bradley Cooper who comes up a
little short in the movie after having a
small Cameo
anyway out on the road they made allies
including a con man 4 Jan the sorcerer
Simon they also met a mysterious
character called lady Sofina who he
later learn is a red wizard a lot of
their backstories are actually expanded
upon in the comic honor among Thieves
the Feast of the moon this prequel story
talks about some of the heights they
pulled off oh Rana failed to pull off
and if you want to learn more from this
world then I highly recommend you pick
it up as for Savino we discovered that
she's actually an ally desai's Tam a
powerful Lich who works with with eight
members of the Council of zulkeers
zaztam is the zulkier of necromancy and
he wished to raise an army of
zombie-like slaves that would do its
bidding a paladin named zank was a
witness to this when it was first
carried out and he barely managed to
escape with his life intact
we're thieves but we helped the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blazer because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you masquerading as an ally sophina got
the group to do a job they attempted to
steal a tablet of Reawakening which is
when she casted time dilation spell that
held Eden Holger in place now it was
during this that Safina was enacting her
real plan which was to grab a horn that
was necessary for carrying her the spell
turns people into Tick-Tock users hey
you haven't that it's fine I I think
they've all turned off the video by now
anyway now Eden Holger were jailed which
is how we opened the movie and after
they managed to escape we follow as they
travel to Neverwinter in order to get
Kira back Ford was tasked with guarding
her whilst they were away and we
discovered that Safina had the lord of
the realm under a spell which allowed
Forge to take over his place since then
he's poisoned Kira against her father
and has made him out to be the bad guy
because he just basically wants a kid
that he can mull to admire him anyway
after they managed to escape execution
the pair team up with Simon once more
and they also meet a tiefling druid
who's called Doric she's the it girl in
this movie and they do an absolutely
fantastic one take scene in which he
spies on the castle and makes a
breakthrough while shape-shifting into
different animals it's really Stella
stuff and when talking about this movie
to both of my friends I've described it
as being like a fantasy Mission
Impossible there's a ton of personality
to it and a lot of scenes in which they
set one thing up have to divert into
another thing and then go back to the
original plan which then all goes to
hell it's really well written and put
together leading to Dynamic action
scenes that are filled with humor and
charm it's the most bloody Chris Pine
Chris Pine Movie you'll ever see and it
primarily centers around the group
getting the tools so that they can storm
the city during the heist and games
sophina has enabled Forge to host the
biggest one yet and this will bring
people together from all over the realm
that she can convert into puppets
meanwhile Forge will make off with all
the wealth that the elite bring to the
city and this will become very rich
whilst they become very dead now they go
to a graveyard which is where they
Resurrect The Dead using spells so that
they can ask them five questions this
actually plays in the post credit scene
of the movie with them constantly coming
up with Loose Ends due to most of the
soldiers not really seeing what happened
because they died before things played
out sometimes they'll discover this
early on and realize that they don't
need to ask five questions to get what
they need unless they'll just ask
arbitrary ones to let the soldiers Rest
in Peace by that the last one tells him
about sync who helped with his passing
the team eventually track him down but
they don't bother asking the rest of the
questions to kill this guy off and the
post-credits scene is just this guy
sitting in a grave asking where everyone
is and maybe maybe like in a sequel they
can get this guy back it's like part of
the team just just don't ask his name or
who his favorite YouTube channel is
because we all know it's gonna be see a
chump anyways things sort of takes them
on a side quest which I loved seeing
play out because it's kind of like this
meta commentary on NPCs and how they act
man even walks in a completely straight
line line and though he doesn't add much
to the story it's just fun seeing these
sort of quests brought to the big screen
he takes them to where he hid the helmet
of disjunction and again this is sort of
a side quest lava location in which they
get some bonuses and have a boss fight
they encounter some of sophina's Undead
forces and we also meet a dragon who's
being described as fat smog
anyway they get out and using the hither
tether staff and helmet at the group
managed to make it inside the castle
whether they're captured which is when
they put themselves forth to enter the
games they managed to break them escape
and gotta leave on forge's bow with
riches but after seeing sophina is going
to transform those in Neverwinter they
decide to take her down leads to a
brilliant final battle and in the end
the group ended up coming out on top
this is because Kira straps a bangle to
safina's wrist so the heisen games were
using to hamper their abilities however
Holger is stabbed during this by
safina's blade meaning that she can't be
resurrected using normal means however
Ed now has his hands on the tablet of
Reawakening and though he'd like to use
it to bring back his wife he realizes
that hulge is very much a mother Akira
she raised her since she was young and
now Ed would love for his wife to be
there he sees that the family Kieran
AIDS was right there in front of him all
along he set out to bring Zia back but
in doing this he lost years with his
daughter when he and Holger could have
just stayed and raised her together in
the end for gorgeous locked up and the
grouper declared Heroes with the Lord
waking up once more and reeling the
realm Borge tries a similar Escape Plan
with Jonathan but they introduced some
health and safety measures and the
window used at the start is now boarded
up anyway there's still a lot of things
in play for a sequel and though
nothing's been announced so far we do
have some things that could come into
play in the future we're discussing if
they had any ideas the creative team
said they didn't want to jinx things and
basically stated when do you start
shooting number two ask us on April 1st
yeah yeah we're very superstitious we
don't like to talk about that kind of
stuff but if we were so lucky we would
love to get back together with this
family you have the fantasy thought out
already the fantasies waiting now the
true big bad of Dungeons and Dragons
that are among Thieves is says Tam due
to his many appearances in the novels
games and Baldur's Gate series we
actually know a fair bit about him
Baldur's Gate 2 gets name dropped
several times in the film and
potentially we could feature more
aspects of that that in further
installments anyway saz was born in the
air of the Dark Dawn in 1104 Dr under
the name tarloth normanda he started
building his allies in puppets and he
would often sponsor groups of people to
retrieve magical artifacts for him these
people were killed upon handing them
over and you also obtained a 700 year
old crystal ball which became one of his
most prized possessions this enhanced
disabilities and after killing his
mentor he learned of his ways eventually
he carried out his First Act of
necromancy on him and this allowed him
to bring his teacher back to life from
this point on he adopted the mindstay
that nobody should go to waste he
started putting his plans in place to
turn everyone into a zombie oh here
we go again succeeding the previous cell
care of necromancy he became a powerful
wizard and this was before he turned
into a lich eventually he became the
region of they but as we see in the
movie he ended up retreating to the
Shadows now this guy is basically a
Thanos and he spent hundreds of years is
trying to regain his powers and put his
plants into place should we get another
movie then I definitely think that it
would scent more around him and his
possible quest for revenge against our
heroes they're just taken out Sofina and
as we saw early on in the movie with
Sierra the red Wizards have a need for
vengeance so I can't see him setting
other villains on them as well and
what's great about this world is that
the movies can have a range of them for
example this film had antagonists like
the dragon I'm not going to body shame
anymore Forge and so on and so forth
however you can have your overarching
evil threats too which really adds to it
and that's what I think is the beauty of
this movie as well I had a really good
time with it and in an age where comic
book movies are falling flat it's nice
to see that the other genres are
crushing it right now and creating
entertainment that leaves you wanting
more I think this movie is really well
cast and every actor sinks into the role
and just becomes the character rather
than you looking at the person who's
playing them it's like a fast and the
furious Lord of the Rings game Game of
Thrones crossover that travels the realm
giving us ice cold locations luscious
countrysides expansive cities and lava
fill layers the pacing is perfect too
and you're never in one place too long
to get bored with constant new
characters and twists keeping you on
your toes I don't think the movie is
perfect at that point it does feel like
they're kind of finding their feet in
what they want from this world but I
think it's one of those franchises where
if they get a second film they'll
absolutely knock it out the park
everything works really well in this
movie and I hope that it gets the Box
off as it deserves I know Dungeons and
Dragons it is a massive name but it also
somehow feels like the underdog and I
think people should give it a chance I'm
not a massive D fan you know I have some
fun with it on a Friday night back when
I was a kid before girls uh and I think
this is but yeah I think this is written
perfectly for to be welcoming to
newcomers whilst also having aspects of
it that hardcore fans will love in the
end this was a really good film and
that's why I'm giving it an 8.5 out of
10. I might tweak that two and nine
after a second watch but you know we'll
keep it 8.5 for now and yeah my
recommendation comes with that as well
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
that's it exactly that you bring to this
I'm a planner I make plans you've
already made the plant so if the
existing plan fails I make a new plan so
you make plans that fail no he also
plays the loot not relevant
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know we are in a competition
right now giving away the Superman 4K
box set of three subscribers on the 15th
of April normally you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film
repeat the comments at random on the
15th then the winners of the last one
are on screen are now so that's you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
build something else to watch so make
sure you check out our Brighton of John
Wick which will be linked on screen
right now that's the other big film at
the moment to dub the ad over there
right after this because there's a lot
of things to talk about especially with
that post credit scene by the way thanks
for singing through the video I've been
Paul you've been the best and you're
bored hey you're bored from coming back
to these videos
I'll see you next time much love